David Spade's on the show today but
first the cats now the show is brought
to you by the cash app which is the
number one finance app in the App Store
cash a business and receive money
especially when your friends oh yeah
stop interrupting me or when you have
them I was gonna say that some of your
time you've used it I'm really into the
cash app I mostly send money to my
friend Nick when he watches the dogs oh
that's really nice I do that I know I'm
a good seven times we hang out and then
I send in money and he's like are you
just paying you to be your friend at
this point yes isn't that how real
friendships were like Dominic - yep
easiest way to try and grow your money
in the stock market with their investing
flesh ha with Koch ah you can easily
invest the stock as little as $1 again
the guy that runs this copy is hot we
need to get this right whoa is that your
sexy voice
Naveed navin's listening you guys and
he's hot did you know that brokerage
services are provided by cash up
investing a subsidiary of square and
member si PC novita like that well now
you do and as always when you sign up
for the cash app and use the promo code
Whitney not only will you instantly
receive $10 but the cash app will also
donate ten dollars to The Trevor Project
which is an amazing organization that
provides Protective Services to lgbtqia+
youth across America
don't forget the promo code Whitney when
you download the cash app from the App
Store today
[Music]
this is fucking tricked out what do you
think this is I thought wasn't bullshit
I thought it was some bullshit yeah I'm
trying it was beautiful I wear blue and
you've got a blue back no no you look
fucking great I can look I get about one
day a week where I do all right are
everyone's phones off except don't worry
your fucking internet cutoff up six
miles ago was locked up front for two
hours going he was out there for 15
minutes you guys I went out there and he
had already like be funny your neighbor
goes he might she might be in that old
podcasts room or whatever they do over
there I go me exactly the more whatever
they do part this is an old-fashioned
whore saloon over there I am really
trying to avoid my neighbors like now
that you've gotten intimate no he was
nice he just said I'll have my son
rappel over and because I was buzzing to
game I don't know what's going on I
think she should be here are you Dave Oh
Diddy oh no I don't care he was what are
you here for the podcast I go booty call
whatever you wanted the kids don't like
me because this house it was between me
and Kid Cudi and the honey and he's so
bummed that I got the house shit one
bomb they even said to me that could
have been a hit podcast yeah they were
like he really wanted Kid Cudi to move
in next door and you got it and I was
like I'm so sorry for the people at home
they don't know this is a huge lot
here's a lot it's a beautiful huge
corner lot it's like it's a coldest it's
the cut they called a sack of a
cul-de-sac really I do have to put the
headphones on because I can what I think
it's funny because I asked you I go do
we wear the headphones and you're like
people don't wear headphones I didn't
know I thought we took calls I thought
we're like a radio no I think that I
know the guests that do podcasts usually
don't wear them Rogen's the only person
that wears them that's where I get
thrown when I see these I think D'Elia
does too maybe
does Chris wear them well that's to
cover his receding hair looks good today
thank you I
I'm glad that you cut it but I like it
it looks good you don't you think I look
worse no you don't look where's your
very pretty and your great hair thank
you
I remember I told you a pretty on the
show yeah oh no jokes just I couldn't
tell I can know everyone all my friends
like you I just went with my realtor I
looked at a house the way out here
really and uh
are you moving I don't know but I think
you should
good old Stewart veteran over it up
Hilton Island he's my guy but he's been
showing me for two years and I keep
kicking tires I'm the worst oh I looked
at houses for I want to say three and a
half years and it's so I found this
place that's so funny you just said that
because that doing a real estate a local
real estate reverence I think the first
time I was like I love him is when you
were on Howard this is ages ago and you
made a reference to Z Gallerie I love it
would how many people are gonna get that
job it's funny now 3,000 he talks I go
where'd ya go Howard hurt you this couch
Z Gallerie I think nobody gets that joke
I love a one percenter I love it cuz you
get it you know I get it it was for me
and I drove up here people don't know
that Whitney lives out sort of in the
middle
coyote centrally well I actually thought
it was farther what does TRT mean over
there we've only been on two minutes Oh
total running time
no we haven't started yet why are we
starting I mean what does this feel like
hot content it's great what it's not
gonna get any better than shit what are
we gonna do we got to do games is it I'm
not on Kelly Clark do you know when we
met David does this count as talking
goddamn this is like when I did norms
and he goes I go we I need he goes I
don't know I don't know he goes alright
it's over I know I had a I to wrap
myself on norms Oh was that norms
Netflix show Norma Donald's Netflix Shh
vodka short I loved that show yeah made
me laugh so hard and made me so
uncomfortable that's what it was and so
I was like if this is a rough cut like
yeah that's it it was if you like they
put they for
they put the wrong version on I I agree
that that's that was sort of the idea
and it turned out like that because I
even said I can't do that long like
let's just milk me you know as I heard
Chevy Chase did three hours I got no
fucking chance
I'm not even interesting for six minutes
I disagree
you don't do a lot of podcasts though
you're too famous for this shit I don't
know if it's too famous I think it's uh
you just feel raped no I know but you
know what I mean you feel like times up
on people asking you to do these stories
in me and then I feel like I'm getting
boring because you just it's sort of the
Comedy Store is a lot a lot of people do
podcast they've been doing for years and
it's more lately and I'm sure I'll do
one it's not there's nothing negative
against that it's just you probably feel
bad because now you have one and you've
you're a great guest so when you go on
stuff some people probably say hey you
and you might but it can vary from a
nice one like this or daliyah's those
guys have great ones down to some guy
let's go hey I'm and I'll hammer in my
mom's laundry room and she'll be drying
boots that day but you know we can cut
the noise out later I go to no hombre
you know I don't even know how I go oh
wait you come to me they go ideally you
drive me even Marc Maron that was that's
in the middle of sticks too but yeah but
Eastside it's a great one and we had a
great once you do get there and do it it
was a great time I liked you on Marc
Maron I had never heard it and I liked
it because it seemed like you guys
didn't know each other that well we
don't any do you hear me said he didn't
really like yes at the beginning and I
didn't mind that because I go he's just
being straight up well he's probably I
think he admittedly was like projecting
because you like did well with women oh
I mean that sort of trips me up but I
was like why and then they go Ryan's he
curses going out Julian often like what
a dick immediately I get mad so I go oh
is that kind of a people so I I see what
that was and I was just thinking heather
locklear lives even farther than you out
here really so when we went out it was a
hike Wow okay she's I was in Oaks that's
very far yeah so that was like at five
o'clock you want to buzz out I'm like or
I think I wait for traffic
totally forgot you guys dated hell
that go on I don't know about a year
maybe is it weird to date someone that
you was famous but you don't I mean like
that one was a little different because
and first of all I'm only talking about
because everyone just figured it out
after a while but during it I didn't
want to say anything but now I wouldn't
sort of put it together and she doesn't
care at all so but it I grew you know
not grew up on our we're what probably
same age I don't know fuck you know I
mean oh no no you and I see you're way
younger you can be my daughter but well
I Heather and I are about the same and
then of course I grew up you're too
young when she was like on posters and
she was on these shows and I was
obsessed with her I'm so sever yeah all
my first and so she got and then she did
SNL when I was there and I was a writer
but I didn't have anything to do on that
show to do a joke so I go so she comes
on SNL everyone does bits but I'm not
really anything with her and then later
I ran into her and she said I remember
you from my Stalin and then she she she
was anyway they were we met and she said
let's hang out as friends so we on out
but she her marriage was going
immediately had a horrible turn of all
these events so we just hung out for a
while and then we kind of dated after
that but it was it was I was right there
being friends there while the whole
thing collapsed and I shouldn't talk
about it but is it hard she's great is
it hard for someone to when you're
dating someone famous to stop thinking
them as famous does it ever do they ever
stop well you just get constantly
reminded because wherever we go everyone
yeah sir ah but she was the typical
things that are fun she's upbeat she's
funny she doesn't take herself seriously
she's something like that you said once
I think I was on Howard that there's no
good way to break up with someone right
away
yeah there's no I was just because I've
been on both sides of it obviously and
in high school I was getting dumped
right and left and then I'm always
trying
if if it's me to ramp it down like it
sounds so horrible but believe me it's
them doing it's me 98 cents but when
that I do it I would say hey and then
they go what we need to talk in person
because you don't you don't know no you
don't know you don't because all it is
is an awkward conversation block block
delete Mahalo
move on and report there's no like we're
breaking up we're gonna let go talk in
person and get closure it never goes
well always drags out there's no good
way to do it you're the one you you get
I don't know why you get it but you do
and well let's I want to break up with
you now the negotiating Stars right
because I've been talked back into
dating and I'll meet you I've seen years
I tell you what two more months and I'm
like yeah you mean we do this by the way
wouldn't do people do it to me I get so
weirded out I go okay like I'm like oh
you don't like me anymore like what am I
doing here like why would I talk you in
yes this is a pilot season and I've
tried to talk them into picking up my
pilot I'm like listen it's a little
rough right now where I can do some easy
tweak recast yes may be recast but we
couldn't license that music and that's
what stuff so but when I've been dumped
I don't know the girl for probably a
year and a half and then they go I
started speaking she's making another
guy and I go someone said that to you
yeah and I go are you shitting me
ah and Ike and I hit up she didn't
answer she didn't answer and then she
finally called Mike she's like what and
I go oh I was just I heard this stupid
thing like you were making I wasn't got
a party and you said he was your
boyfriend she was are you gonna get all
weird about this and I just go nope
and then that was it we hung up and I
was like oh and then we didn't talk for
months and and of course it killed me
inside then I go what do I say to her
when I call her nothing to say and I
probably did back then go we just saw
but yeah yeah my side is I want to talk
back in well all that's ego it's all ego
and you're trying to manage the pain
it's trying to stop the bleeding it's
trying to just change the end of the
story
so gross because the fact that she was
so grossed out by me texting or calling
after that I'm like I'm the great guy
from a week remember like you were so
into it how old was this person well I
was I'm sure by the way I definitely
probably did that when I was young you
know I mean of course I was like I just
expect everyone to read my mind so I'm
like oh no we broke up in my head like a
week ago well that's our part but but I
would get the most Kurt the point was I
get the most Kurt endings of like a
quick text if they're gonna be that
friendly about it mmm hey it's not
working for me
what's not working and then nothing and
then you're like I love you said this he
did it over text didn't if you do over
the phone he did it over the phone yeah
he fucking did it in person there's just
any of you in person they go you fucking
broke up you drive all the way over
yeah person it's all bad if you stick to
your guns and if you say it's even when
you say like no to a project or
something and they go kind of call you
and then it's the horrible call this
you're trying to hang up still saying no
their whole call is going to get you say
yes and it's so it's pointless you go
why I here's my answer at least
understand that but no one will let you
say doh
and if you say no to something we were
talking about this the other day if you
say no to something now you then Oh them
a favor down the line I can't do it okay
well circle back I go no no it's like
can you do this charity show you know I
can't I'm on tour and then a month later
hey so can you help me find someone for
the charity show it's like no I don't
know oh yeah I work for you because I
wasn't able to do it yeah I I you know
we all get caught in those things and
I'm I ask favors and I'm get asked
favors I'm on both sides of it it's
always weird so it's just a tough thing
I don't know do you remember how we met
let's look at a clip I don't I don't eat
but I do remember no I do I think tell
me if this is true at sour there was a
party it Tower bar and you had done your
show and you came and I said I think
that's Whitney Cummings and I said I do
or something huh is that making I was in
a total blackout during that time
completely unconscious consumers here
probably thought that tracks but I
remember the first time we talked to the
phone and I don't know why boom
we spoke on the phone for 45 minutes one
time this was when I think your show you
weren't sure if it was coming back or
not and mine I wasn't sure if it was
coming back or not and you called me and
we talked about it all about it and you
said something that kind of changed my
life you said bad news travels slow
that's sure I had never heard that
before because we were like waiting
around to hear and you're like if we
haven't heard the answers probably not
it's very true about a lot of stuff and
you said like when the ratings are good
everyone wants to call you and be the
first person to give you the good news
if you don't hear about the ratings
right away they're not good that's the
thing it's gross and that and they and
they all want to be the one connected
with telling you good news always so
they got the best phone calls or when
they go okay David we've got a girl it's
Adam Bennett and Brad grey on the line
and I was like this is good news because
they all want to go hey we did it right
but if it's bad news they're all in a
media until someone gets to give it to
you that it didn't something didn't work
I know that is tough I uh that's it
it's tough biz you I feel like I look at
you all the time I like I can't believe
how nice you are to people well weird ah
yeah and I think even George Segal when
I used to do that just shoot me show
which by the way can you imagine a show
being called just shoot me right now in
this climate yeah I can't even I came to
a joke one no yeah George said the
number one question he got was he seems
like an asshole
is he an asshole Roper in real life
because I think on the show I play like
super smart ass you know yeah but he
says surprisingly he's not that bad and
I do think I know you're one of the
nicest people in comedy I think well I'm
nice to you I like you and we get along
but I'm pretty nice real friends yeah
we're real friends well I wouldn't I
would try not to do this kind of thing
if we weren't but I do crack up at you
and you always by the way you're very
reliable when you do my show which is
only a new part of our friendship it's
fun to see at the store it's fun to see
out but you're very there's a lot of
kind
very flaky yeah and you're sort of in a
different world and you're in a
different headspace in your if you say
you're doing something you do it and
you're good and you show up but that but
doing my show is just recent but I've
known you for a long time before that
and you've always been solid person but
I know that it's always it's such a
nightmare doing a show like that cuz
you're booking what five times fifteen
comics a week you have enough to worry
about people canceling last-minute it's
just like so if I'd never want to be
that for someone cuz that bit on the
other side of it and it's the worst yeah
and you're not Ben if you do you're
professional about it but sometimes you
get calls at noon oh I'm like is this
the fucking Improv like are you
canceling your spot tonight it's
different if it's a whole TV show and
everything's based on you and we might
have bit for you or questions just for
you whatever so we do deal with that but
I would I don't like it I mean unless
it's something legit I don't like to
hear do you like doing the show I do
like doing the show it's it's harder
than I thought and I know you've done so
many yeah it's better than the first
time I did a Comedy Central show the
showbiz show it was once a week and it's
just too hard to get momentum for me
once a week it's also a hit oh the show
yeah yeah the shows good well it helps
that it's it's hot four in a row and
then there's momentum it's like seen
otherwise you know you see a clip of it
the clutter that's right it's like
broken down into little memes and then a
meme and then you go they have a little
YouTube it and they have this and you
know you have fan comedy central to get
a app to watch it and you go on the
website but each each company you work
whether each channel has their own way
to do it it yeah I wish it was a little
easier for people just go on YouTube
watch the whole thing or the next day
you can watch on Comedy Central I think
for free on their website but it's just
most people piecemeal it to be on right
like I but you know I ran into Ted you
know Ted from Netflix runs Netflix and
he and he was he sometimes will text or
say something nice about the show and it
was very flattering that he was going
remember that week you were sick every
show was good even though you could tell
your voice is bad and I was like you've
seen you actually watching shows when
you have 85 shows in production because
yeah it's on before bed and mobile
so and also and this is so smart that
there's no politics in the job yeah that
loves that the thing that sort of hooked
people in or lets more people come on
even when we have people that are
political like you can have a side
that's political but people leave it at
the door they come and they go oh and if
they're good they go oh I can be funny
and just be funny like I always want you
know like are you ever in the writers
room in a political joke yes good joke
but we can't do it of course I wish we
could get by with and then when the
impeachment came up there's so many
jokes and I think I'm thinking of and
you just we do a whole show without it
don't even mention and we're like the
only show that doesn't even act like
it's not think but sometimes someone
says oh you said something last week and
I go Whitney you teetered over but it's
just even funny
me saying Whitney it looks more real no
it's true we try to keep in stuff I like
you make it very conversational and
really fun and it's it's interesting cuz
it's just it's so hard to cut through
the clutter right now it's weird how it
is hard and it's still it'll be hard but
you know I am a white guy and I don't
think anyone's pulling for the white
like I'm old rich white it's like every
fucking horrible thing going against me
yes and I should be like the shit kicked
out of me I mean I'm just short of
apologies I like it's not everyone's
like did you do your apology and I'm
like I don't think I'm gonna do one I'm
just this is how I was born I I'm just
trying to struggle through so what I'm
saying is I don't think you can read an
article like Aquafina has a show yeah
and she's very funny she sort of
discovered in a weird way we put her in
something she was great
yeah and then she gets a show and funny
funny she's great I don't know I've
heard a very sweet person but it's
easier to write if you're a writer to
say this is a great show much because it
is important yeah getting a break for
her she has an Asian cast she has
writers you know it was like when
Schumer and then it's women this is a
porting show for women watch we are
writing it we're doing women's issues
right if it's Chris Rock putting
together something is that this is but
if you're just like here
we're going just watch I'm not even
we're not saying anything we're just I'm
just doing straight jokes about just
anything stupid because there's not I
have nothing important thing which is
very true I don't and I don't have an
opinion I don't I mean I know you you're
a fascinating person like I love talking
about stuff that you don't talk about on
TV but I do think there's just something
refreshing about a comedian not telling
you how to vote right
it's just something refreshing about an
actress not telling you what you should
think right politics you know it's odd
because I get why people do it and I
think people say oh you're not brave
enough to get on Instagram and tell I
said I this is a personal choice I also
if I have a health issue I don't have to
get an improper Instagram and tell
everyone I mean there's personal things
politics might be personal to people
yeah your health is personal but you
decide you want to talk about to talk
about you're also gonna get some flak
there's this new thing now that we're
people like you need to use your
platform and oh yes way that's like hold
on I feel like the best service we can
maybe do at this point is give people a
break from that shit and not I don't
love you know is me eating it all day
yeah it's exhausting and I don't know I
think that sometimes the best thing way
a lot of people in Hollywood can use
their platform right now is not make the
left look like a bunch of idiots that
sure are on CW shows and think I know it
well to be quite qualified I'll say
something if I'm educated on it I just
am not educated enough right it's bad
enough me trying to push Tummie t like
guys you want to look like me either
like know who does I'm like oh well but
III agree that it everyone has opinions
and I don't mind when people do it
if it's jammed on my throat it's hard
yeah it's a mute people or you feel
horrible when you go I just gotta jump
off for a while because I can't read it
every day but it's it's each person's
decision I think people don't want it
for me and I don't really want to do it
you also don't go after celebrities in a
way that's super mean I don't and we
made a conscious effort on the show to I
would kill a lot of jokes and it takes a
lot of training in the writers room some
of them are roast writers and right
they're going for the jugular but I said
listen if we're gonna have any
raishin here and we're gonna stay on for
a while we've got a tone it down and
just keep it clever like if something
happens with someone I think we get a
freebie yeah but we can't just keep
hammering for the sake of hammering and
it gets too mean yeah I don't want to do
that I want to keep it fun and clever
and I make fun of myself too but we have
jokes like we had one the other day that
I do but it made me like it was
Weinstein trout the funny things are
like Weinstein and people you can joke
about no one can really get mad does the
same are Callie or something so so we
just take goofy potshots but it was you
know he brings his walker and yeah they
say his lawyers think this is just like
The Fast & Furious franchise it's always
easier to watch or the Walker you know
or something like I think it's great
yeah yeah put it in so I did it but
there's some I pull back I need one
about Brad and Jen that's very dicey
very die because she's you're friends
with Jen which sounds weird to say but
friendly with Jen's with Jen friendly
always get smart water do you want to
see yourself no but I'm turning around
you look very good are you going back
like this okay so oh yeah I should do
that
you should do it open it up nice waist I
don't know Brad Pitt though so Brad is
dear friend Brad can deal with me if I
see him can use it I think you okay so
I've seen Brad mostly because we have
the same management oh that's right it
doesn't know we're moving up so that
you're not it's Brad is with Brillstein
and so I've seen him over the years of
things and he did a bit for me on SNL a
long time ago which was nice because he
doesn't who I said no a lot
he said one bit you know he seems very
chill very chill
we sounds too super talking want someone
like Brad Pitt but just to give him his
props very chill always friendly always
friendly to people that come up to him
yeah for being that superstar status
yeah I get nervous talking to him I
don't even know what to say the fucking
guy right but he's very cool and and his
speeches lately he's very funny
like that siding later again because yes
I think when it come here data Jen and
that Angelina think it's just so like
people get so fucking into it and he's
like only teams women have yeah that's
true they don't have football you know
Super Bowl all boys Redskins we get it
Angelina it's like we have to pick a
side yeah and it's it's funny cuz Brad
wasn't I don't think allowed to be happy
for a long time like here he can't show
it yeah with Jen did yeah they love Jen
yeah and then the Angelina thing was of
course let the guy do it you know yeah
but when it's funny cuz when Jen's
involved she's so beloved yeah is there
a more beloved person it's unreal and
then Jen Sandra Bullock are so nice
anyway in Centreville tonight they yet I
get it and I you have to be a dancer on
jokes on them because I think they
understand they're part of the mix but I
am gonna give him a break I'm not gonna
know it's go hard after them oh I said
Brad and Jen were even saying and I get
scared I go don't worry I don't think
she's everyone was excited cuz Brad and
Jen were backstage chatting sparks were
flying when they were talking backstage
I said also sparks are flying at
Angelina's house when she threw rocks at
her TV and people like fuck you Angelina
why would you ever sit she's a goddess
and I was like I'm not trying to get and
believe me and they went bananas she
wasn't watching she I said she's got
Sudan pax is it Shiloh's not nope
not among the ones they haven't named
yet aren't know they're all don't name
TBD she's directing the World War one
movie somewhere yes Lavinia she's
pitching a depressing movies in that
flicks I have a this is just celebrity
gossip I have I was at one of those
Golden Globes parties once yeah this is
a spate episode it you know like sunset
our what we met at that Hotel and
Angelina Jolie was there and no one was
talking I saw her I swear to God I was
it though maybe the same one she was out
outside that door sitting on it no I was
talking to her and I didn't know what to
do
I almost went and talked to her and she
looked like she wanted to socialize I
think she's just
so intimidating and and no one really
knew how to offer guys it looks like
you're hitting on and that's why I
didn't just did go say aye
I've seen it an old gym I used to go to
and she would say she was sweet I have
to put this in when I ran into her
briefly in the old days very sweet and I
even couldn't go up and say anything to
her because I thought oh don't talk to
her well you could have cuz you could
just say hey if you're a fan people say
we look alike we should hey we're
beautiful sisters you know what's
grosser I'm gonna give you a question
okay what's grosser okay it's hard for
me as a guy to like I've never asked
Brad Pitt for his number I've never
asked almost any but you male celebrity
I mean for their number a guy a saint
guy for number is weird
no the way you have to do it is to just
go oh do put your number and I'll send
you that thing oh my god I cry so sick
in case they go uh and I'll be like oh
my god they just paused and because he's
not my Instagram either well Brad I mean
I would I wouldn't do it but but I don't
like anyone I would meet I feel like I
feel how does a guy do it so I'm a guy
you want to be friends with what do you
do we should hang out man oh I'm scared
I would go uh meanwhile every fucking
ass wants me for him on the street i
spayed I go finger
dude I do a bunch of fucking producing
sugar so three one oh what is it I'm
like well wait what's going on
like it's so fast that I don't even know
and I go I'd say it they go let me call
it right here I'm calling right buddy
it's not ringing I go it's on and then I
get scared and I go here's the real and
I give the real when I walk away
spinning on Rogers yeah but what just
happened like I told one guy no knees a
huh
I go I got all weirded out because I go
I can't give you my fucking but I can't
say that really feel like they're
friends with you I've seen the way
people approach you and it is alarming
weather that I I've been out with guys
that are like celeb types and they
always are intimidated by them and
they're not intimidated I mean they just
Bader know people think um guys are
friendlies and they're they're doing you
a favor by saying hi you want to feed
them yes see I think it's because what
is that because I think part of its cuz
you're stand up yeah and part of it
because I play like a
off Fraternity fungi joder guys so but i
also it's more approachable your the
movies that you make and i did like a
ask spade questions on my instagram yeah
the people that watch your movies watch
them over and over and over again like i
don't have so just yeah the ones they
like times like it they're like i think
they think they have spent time with you
i agree i mean i feel do you ever say
you feel safe celeb types where you
think you know them and you don't know
if you've met him like if I said Santa
Brooks am I go I know same coffee bean
or I think I know I'm that they're a
star but I don't know if I've ever met
him anywhere right so I just go fuck it
but a lot of them give you celebrity
courtesy where they will just say hi and
they don't make you go through a whole
stress thing like I got even know if I
met you fight and they go oh hey they're
usually pretty nice yes no I'm sure I'm
saying they don't I get a lot of career
advice put you through the shit oh they
do the poor people are like astounded
that I'm not in certain things like
people be like how come you're not
Wonder Woman like I'm just I I didn't
return the call I just was busy I got
busy that you make more money turning
down things and then you have to get and
then you have to explain to them while
you're not successful or baby sure you
are yeah I know how do you show why is
he you Sean it's all why are you
nominated for the golden higher now and
then I have to go well because they
don't want me to be like I don't know
you like there's no way to say it but
it's so kind because it's obviously
somewhat I mean something leaves in you
so much and you gonna have to explain to
them why you're not as successful I also
get I have this theory that the third
thing someone says to you is always an
insult because it's their honest
reaction to seeing you oh good so he
will be like um I love you such a big
fan you're so much bigger in person in
fairness you are yeah you're huge aura I
love you I love your life special
you look pretty young actually like what
like just you I have to get after the
second thing I just have to walk away
what's what's what do you want to here's
a girl cuz this happened at work the
other day you tell me this is rude I
didn't say it okay but me and my guy
friends who are all dumb
bathing that he said to the girl you
look prettier in real life great
question
just I just what what's the what are you
trying to get is it flirty it sounds
like a probably a flirt didn't go for it
but that means every if someone said to
me I think every other time which every
the world sees me it's bad yeah yeah
yeah but one at a time I'm good
that's sort of what you're saying people
say that's me all the time you're so
much prettier in person I'm like well
the thing that matters I'd rather look
better with all the lighting and makeup
and whatever right I don't I think when
people say that a lot of times they're
panicking or they want to say you're
pretty hey that's right they're just
trying to say you're pretty and they
don't know how because it's weird to go
you're pretty that's a weird thing to
say but also it makes me think of which
really annoys me when guys say you're so
much prettier without makeup that that's
what annoys that row is that a vanillin
that's it's just first of all I'm sure
I've said that it's not if it's
professional makeup only if I did it
myself number one and then why are all
your favorite porn stars wearing clown
makeup it confuses us because it's sort
of like I'm different I tell girl I go
you can you got another layer and you
get better you also don't know what
makeup is see I don't know even what's
happening when girls go what about when
they're in scrim they go makeup free and
you're like I have girls go let me see
that
yeah oh filters and mascara and she's
not totally in base we were talking
about a girl you were dating and you're
like she came out in like a teddy
haha is that all is that all no I'm sure
it was a nightgown
[Music]
ha get numb good number most guys have
tried different ways to last longer lots
of very weird ways as my guess but
saying the Pledge of Allegiance in your
head are counting backwards from 10 does
not always work so countdown blast-off
the folks at Roman men's health company
are changing the game with Roman swipes
the secret to longer-lasting sexuals
have that long sex romance whites are
clinically proven as a way to last
longer and better effective they're easy
to use fast-acting but don't require a
prescription this is a genius invention
I really I really wish I thought of this
we'd be so rich Roman can ship swipes to
you in a discreet unmarked packaging
each packet small enough to hide in your
wallet for whatever you need it swipes
will not transfer to your partner that's
pretty genius easy to use takes wipes
out of the packets swipe it on let it
dry good to go have that all not sexuals
get $10 off your first order of swipes
and free 2-day shipping at get Roman
dot-com / Whitney that's get Roman
dot-com / Whitney $10 off and 10 our sex
free two-day shipping get Roman comm /
Whitney get thrustin they left in our
Skillshare does Skillshare make a video
to teach podcast hosts how to read ads k
well after this this is the fourth time
I've read my Skillshare ad it's time to
explore new skills deepen existing
passions get lost in creativity with
skill shares online classes it's an
online learning community where millions
come together they take the next step in
their creative journey thousands of
inspiring classes for creative and
curious people topics like illustration
design photography video freelancing
more more as my favorite or is the best
one I took the productivity masterclass
taught me how to like schedule my time
manage my time working longer is not
always working harder true and the next
one is I want to do a design one a
fashion design class because I want to
make better merchandise for our show
they deserve it you know do you think as
I suckered
fun and picking colors I don't know like
italics yeah they'd be a great class to
just refine your taste a little bit yeah
and I want to learn photography -
because my Instagram photos suck
Skillshare is a proud sponsor of good
for you explore your creativity at
Skillshare comm slash good for you get
two free months of premium membership
that's two whole months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
get started and joined today by heading
to Skillshare comm slash good for you
Skillshare comm slash good for you is
the nightgown older than teddy things
that guys call women's things like
what's the thing that goes on your
eyelids what's that eye mascara the top
part yeah the world top part is
eyeshadow yes and what about this over
the lid the pencil and ring marker i
don't know and what's this with a brush
a brush a bra base brush but a thing
that rouge is really something still as
ruiz gone but how do you get the red
circles on your cheeks and then what's
this a pencil a lipstick a lip edger lip
edge red lipstick no there's a pencil
pencil lip pencil lip liner we can
password no i don't know i am what's the
shiny stuff you put on top lip gloss yes
that's up cos that's funny bell you're
still around
lipsmack lipsmack errs those were
stocking stuffers those are a hot bubble
yum i keep looking at the TV like i'm on
i go like this
i know we can pull it up we know what we
can go out I guess the cameras there
this is pretty professional I swear to
god I thought it would be more what did
you think it was gonna be what do you
think that's ratty like a pup tent crawl
it sets your hook we're the camping you
know no um even though I did pass this
house and I you know if you've gone to
the Australian wildfires you've gone too
far
folks it's far what are you by the girls
that you love for Valentine's Day
no Valentine says chickie what do you do
I don't like it because I feel like
it's a scam just give him the watch
you're wearing this is a good one I know
I'm looking at it you know that your
thing is that we spend money on I only
have one good watch I feel like you
don't spend money a little screwed you
are you know you are and I think people
wonder if I'm rich or not I looked it up
you're Jesus but I I know that's usually
off I mean you're I think they usually
do that with shoveling everything in a
pile that's not doing taxes or that you
live that agents and managers and stuff
like that that is or that you've paid
for anything in here I love celebrity
Network like pull up
celebritynetworth.com I love guessing
people's not as good one you can do a
high like let me throw you one um Daisy
Fuentes oh fuck
who can be the hardest one first Daisy
Fuentes remember Daisy Fuentes she was a
host yeah MTV very nice girl Daisy
Fuentes in the idealist days Gus wait
does she have a clothing line correct he
does goddamn he does she's got like a
Kmart I just sighs okay 14 I'm gonna say
14 million 18 go this is fucked I'm
scared I'm gonna what wait where is it
300 million what get fuck not at 75
million go down here the second one what
the with MTV three hundred million up
what is she Jessica Simpson what if I
just took yes what were the assholes I'm
gonna go work for her I love where
low-balling easy Fuentes damn I thought
I was going high 75 million
she's got exercise club where her
collection I know I'm not going to the
Golden Globes launched a clothing line
hey girl I'll do sponsored content for
daisy fuentes spandex sports bras you
know what your lines be called hey girl
hey girl hey guys hey guys guys guys
alright let's do another one ah I have a
serious subject pilot oh no what is next
one give me somebody good um Ryan
Seacrest okay I ever gonna be hi uh he
produces the credit okay give me known
sindbad sindbad his good jokes ago ever
have underwear sold it's just a rough
man okay
Sinbad I did a gig with and by the way
just well while the Google is you know
computing yeah thanks in a while uh I
did a corporate and he was opening for
me in a strange series and I go oh no
you're going first and I know he's good
I go oh no this is gonna suck and he
goes yeah and he went out and I go what
kind of companies is it Street you know
it's like Orkin or something yeah and I
go oh yeah I go I'm gonna go I'm gonna
leave Orkin yeah don't bug me and then
I'll just go talk so funny Huggle right
under my accent but they'd like you to
incorporate the company you know I don't
you know it's they're like hey Jim's our
VP he's got three balls and beats his
wife working it and then you say it one
guy laughs it back and what else fuck
mom dying it yeah yeah say something the
only things it's funny yeah and then so
Sinbad goes up and rush --is for a solid
half-hour and everyone's like oh he's
like this over Tim over there after like
he's using the microwave he did he like
studied the company and he gets off and
I'm like god dammit I was out there like
fuck someone else I thought he was the
main guy and then I'm like hey everybody
like I'm all cool and they're like but
you know they just they weren't bad but
they were not good and they just sort of
struggled through me and I was like I
just walked out there delirious going
fucking Sinbad killed killed that also
happened once I was doing this event at
the David Lynch foundation it's a it was
a chair it's a charity for meditation
something and I'm cold
no I'm cool wedding look even your
bomber jacket wait is it new 12 grand
it's what did you ask me no it fits good
look is that new
because I told a producer on your show
that you should be wearing bomber jet oh
yeah the show we had a very long
conversation about it yes you told Tom
and Brad are you told no I told Adam
of your producers automating it yes
because on your show I was fucking
looking and you're always in like a ski
jacket
you're always like Amal I am in a and
you're like a North Face ski jacket yeah
like a norm core the cool Silicon Valley
billionaire on vacation and rapper in a
video right ok sin burger said that
words sounds mean if I go low why no I
think ok but he had a sick 12:9 final
answer ok what's yours laughs fifty
seven hundred million what if he
invented something a million Oh
four million this is not fun by the way
four million is a lot damn no this is we
should keep doing super high ones
because we look like assholes formula if
you had four million each jump off a
bridge right here money I'd throw mine
away pretty single and the people you
guys better be guessing this listening
Stacy Keibler she still have the
treehouse for the elves dum-dum oh oh
god damn stay close all right okay
you're always joking video stacey koon
know what oh okay well what was she on
she was on dancing she's a wrestler than
just dancing stars in an actress I don't
know anything about wrestling money I
I think she's married to a very rich guy
cuz I know they bought a house that's
right that post Clooney so what do I say
to that after the after a woman breaks
up a Clooney she gets married within six
months within seconds I know it's it's
the only way out because you can't yeah
what can you do okay what's your guess
I'm gonna say I did she have a line she
have a tanning line or a hair extension
lesson rings doesn't even know this is
no she is no Ben she is young and knows
youtubers I know he's like her on the
David dub kid Casey Kasem okay
no hazy case does not word that much
okay Steve are you are you quietly
you're down no I know you wrote just
shoot me is that how I just wrote it I
was gonna ask about it I think that's
exactly the font on the script it's true
actually you know what I mean I just
look I just shoot me down and it looks
like the font from the from the show go
ya know a lot of people on Instagram
have questions about stuff okay well
I'll get there right after list
basically but I'm gonna say cuz she's
tied in him now 40 million 21 this must
be before they got married yes and boy
sorry for those of you love Hwy 4.5
million for Stacey cubes she's done well
for herself
well there's another 125 million for her
what the fuck are wrong
I think celebritynetworth.com that's the
one I go to that's the one that I what
about the guy Richard Simmons what do
you get horrible why 26 million 30 Ted
tapes you videos yeah what do you think
is a lot of fucking money photo 32
million Richard Simmons Mike final
answer
15 million fuck he got robbed he's been
robbed I know how about this give me one
of your youtubers feel like you get a
bad deal I don't know why you think I
know about all the YouTube you do Taran
what do you want right now are we at
tick-tock dude Trisha Paytas said that
he's obsessed okay Trisha Paytas Trisha
Paytas probably has more money than all
of us combined Trisha Paytas what is she
she's a YouTube star
she eats on camera and she had breaks
down and does she have a brand no does
she have abuser period for YouTube so
ads and applying and and how good sure
okay so but she's got lots of hits on
her YouTube
she also upstreams model-type on top of
everything else yes yes yeah yes tell me
- yes Trisha Paytas so Trisha Paytas net
worth I'm gonna gas girl watches her
five million oh yeah she loves you it is
that I think that's true I think I've
got the end yeah yeah oh okay
so star being nice I'm gonna guess four
three five six six YouTube ad money a
million more money than Stacey keeps I
know you don't
and now that one switched it to four oh
I like this Oh everyone's rich
everyone's rebels getting rich fine but
what if it said like 20 hooray I know
well I mean Logan Paul is probably
jeffree star dude jeffree star net worth
is that one your laser sweat is it
insane cuz he's got makeup lines he's
got the young his health no he owns
Rouge companies he may ruin shrews for
the internet stars great is my Wi-Fi not
working how come let's take it so I
don't even know I'm gonna say Jeffrey
seven five Jeffrey Stehr has what fifty
million YouTube seventeen live I just
changed Instagram in YouTube he's like
he's also like a famous famous now I
haven't made one fuckin penny from
Instagram really you know do weren't we
supposed to do a bridge they are doing
it now we're doing a brand new content
you are together you're not doing that I
I are doing it now we are you and I yeah
it just came up again are you
do you say none of that stuff I've
always said no no I'm not I'm gonna do
with you though oh then we're gonna do
it together it makes to patch together
yeah over the new Sonny and Cher yeah
I'll do with you we'll talk after but do
you woody why do you say notice our
names I think the average person an
average person I just mean that is like
people that watch us like do you guys
think it's corny oh right we when we
should ask your people hi guys because I
I've never done one so I don't need I
just think people think I would be full
of shit if I did I don't they always go
you need money I go I mean when do you
stop greatly I mean Whitney's I'm not
good my net worth I gotta make sure your
net worth is very high Google that
before you came on I don't okay Jeffrey
started net worth I'm gonna say 22 milli
okay Benton insane 31 one no shut the
fuck up 50 he's got like MAC Cosmetics
he's got his own cosmetic line yeah
above forty million I am in the hundreds
and add money from YouTube and and every
this hotels merch you've got a hotel you
all kinds of real estate he talked very
openly about it okay Oh kind of what
real estate Benton is from this real
estate
he's very fancy okay I'm gonna say 45
I'm gonna say 50 v 3c no a game show 200
milli
you knew that are you didn't know he
knew that Benton knew him and I want a
net worth Benton was trying to help us
guys you're fucking I didn't believe
Benton I like someone I've never heard
of his wit that's how out of it I am I
thought you're exaggerating you should
have I mean I don't know it does every
show ever go in TV shows no we should do
a secretary try to become famous makeup
tutorial he just does it did makeup
tutorials on YouTube I'm gonna do makeup
tutorials on makeup people that do it
that's a good idea lip Rouge on them
here's the Rouge base what was the
mysterious thing you want to bring up oh
no I saying my daughter has a father-son
dance coming up what my father I just
thought of Sundance festival what's
happening do you need some sugar I
shouldn't but I but we can catch a
father-daughter dance
and I think even though I'm so old
school nothing bothers me but I think a
father-daughter dances antiquated
and I know I think it's weird I don't
like it and as in you go to the school
and dance with her yes and take her and
I don't live there and so other dad's
dancing with their daughters yes sir let
some Shirley Temple shit it makes
someone feel bad because I'm not there I
don't live in the same States
yeah so I have try to fly in and figure
out work and it's always been a problem
have you gone before I haven't gone
before it's only been for about well
probably last five years and so this
year I was about to do it and then
something came up again but I can't get
out of it and so I always say I can't go
and then I want a surprise but I can't
and so I just said and then I thought
why are they even doing these anymore
yeah make her feel bad every year it
sounds like good there's gonna be kids
whose fathers are
sag around like anything and then but
every year I have to grind it in yeah
and I'm not huh hey cried it in I'm not
we're not gonna be grinding but what is
that but I would go there and let it go
do it what is falling something fell and
I couldn't care less
oh you have a table and you get little
hooks for the headphones I'm the most
fidgety for fun well because I don't
know what bits are is there now and
having pickups
I thought podcast you just bullshit this
is what everyone says ask me a real
conversation I'm always like it is are
they boring like no want they want the
wiretap oh that's what they say the
wiretap they just want to hear you
having a conversation controlled chaos
[Music]
[Applause]
function of beauty this is right up your
alley been to Amsterdam by yourself we
don't all have the same hair so why
should we all use the same shampoo and
conditioner nonsense you don't have to
anymore because of this company it's
called function of beauty function of
beauty is the internet's top-rated
customized hair kerr brand with over
30,000 five-star customer reviews and
ratings cheese's that's really hard to
get to watch yeah curly or straight
natural or processed function of beauty
individually formulates every bottle
based on your unique hair type style
preferences and hair goals where was
function of beauty was I was getting
bullied in high school right damn it
to begin there's just a short for
question quiz you save 20% on your first
purchase go to function of beauty calm /
Whitney tell them about your hair is it
oily is it dry is it thin is it thick
and they will customize a formula ooh
with the fragrance and a color it's also
vegan and cruelty-free you can also go
die in fragrance free this is really
annoying me that this company hasn't
been around longer to get started right
now go to function of beauty.com /
Whitney to take your 4 part hair profile
quiz
save 20% on your first order don't spend
another minute in hair misery like I did
all throughout the 90s go to function of
beauty.com / Whitney to let them know
that we sent you function of beauty calm
/ witness hello beresch my favorite do
you know what I'm referencing hello
fresh yes you know hello nurse but fresh
get mouth-watering seasonal recipes and
pre measured ingredients delivered right
to your door with hella fresh America's
number one meal kit sure we don't do
number twos around here at good for you
number ones only thank you hello
freshest recipes are so delicious you're
gonna break out of that dinner rut 22
Plus that means 22 and more seasonal
chef curated recipes each week not
curated by some willy-nilly person off
the street these are real chefs
low-calorie vegan family-friendly pick
one which one did you pick Benton I've
tried them all I did the variety yeah so
I did all of them I love them I mean I
like to make it it's like 20 30 minutes
depending on the recipe 20 minutes with
a quick recipe option and you know the
average trip to the grocery store takes
how long forty one minute he only knew
that because you read it off the copy
but for me it takes about two hours most
people did not know that that's 35 hours
a year that you are in the goddamn
grocery store and hella fresh is gonna
change that
go to hell of fresh calm / 10 good
that's hella fresh calm / 1 0 good use
code 10 good for 10 free meals including
free shipping 10 goods it's I'm making
it sound harder than it is hello fresh
com / 1-0 g-o-o-d
very simple just use the code 10 good
for Tim's email including free shipping
I felt like I was very clear
that's I like on the show on my show not
to switch it but when people settle in
the other day I was asking Josh I said
that the girl well I said you're baked
her you smoke a lot of weed right and he
goes yeah and then he just started
talking about it and then I go at least
it's real for a second good yeah I mean
our topics are real because I don't know
what they're gonna say yeah people think
we have rehearsal but they're not
rehearsal I just do it to camera block
and say I have to throw to this video I
get confused because I just I feel like
I don't know I feel like not being funny
and makes me panic
well because comedians we're not that
funny when we're not onstage
I agree like we were just taking a tour
of your house and we just we were
actually pretty normal
yeah we were just talking about your
house and moving in and yeah we had a
real authentic moment there right I'm
okay with almost found love but I think
people when they when they see you on
Instagram I think there's you're always
a little bit of the on switch because
you have to be yes cuz that's yes what
you do yes and so do I but I think
comedians specifically feel safe to
being around each other because we know
we don't have to be funny and actually
trying to be funny around comedians you
feel corny you know cuz we've all heard
everything I think that's why we like
hanging out so it's a little against my
nature to go on a podcast and like show
everyone how like kind of boring it yeah
no but you you are a interesting girl
and I think people will trade real I
think they like to just see a little
real bullshitting just to see what are
we like I would be curious to see the
hallway the comedy store I think that's
very riveting to see everyone just say
you see a picture of like you talking to
Rogen or you know Bobby Lee and be like
oh they just hang out yeah it's weird
like - your favorite comics are suddenly
like talking selling you know do they
laugh at each other yeah it I also I
just forget like it's it's just it is so
weird that all of our friends are comics
like it's the it's just the best thing
and I think a lot of times when I that's
why I'm so bad remember how I had like a
meltdown I did this thing at New Year's
Eve huh oh yeah good one which time is
that this abuse I'm calling HR we have
any more of this water would you call
look at this I learned
Sharon school but the you really hydrate
yourself you seem like you're taking
care of yourself well I had to pull over
and pull the tumbleweeds out of my girl
I'm saying how far it is something that
I'm interested in about you is that I
feel like you've been through a lot of
traumatic things and you've handled them
really well as well as possible I mean
you just have to keep you keep going
either way whether you want to or not
you just been through oh you're just
good at grief mmm well it affects me in
weird ways because it's hard to get too
attached
mm-hmm because to new people to new
people I obviously my dating history is
bad
I don't why why well I'm dating someone
now that I'm that I was friends with her
a long time and why is your dating
history bad why didn't why is that I
take a bad rap but but why it's you
you're just everyone dates a lot of
people yours were just in the news cuz
you're famous right and I actually
didn't really one of the news but yeah
there's other people that do it to be in
the news yeah and I learned early on
that that makes it so much harder and
more pressure yeah people like have a
opinion about me to them and yeah
opinion about them to me they wish for
her you know she went out what you know
and then you started getting weird like
wait what and then I heard she's sketchy
you know or whatever yeah yeah and that
and it can ruin things quicker and
forget at the level of these guys like
Brad or yeah that they have to try to
just how would you ever have a date with
this yeah this is so weird so I've gone
through some stuff and I think dating
even marriages don't work so it's not
like saying you should be married that's
the end all and be all
it just makes other people happy why
aren't you married I'm like here's a
fuck like well I find interesting and I
and I am NOT over here I mean it is what
it is of like if a man is single at a
certain age it's like oh he's like why
is he married and if a woman is single
they're like good for you you don't need
anyone
it's switch because it used to be poor
girl yeah because like weddings yeah I
don't like weddings and they make the
fucking single girls pay for everything
like you won you got married like that's
right something instead of like yeah
it's great I'm getting married and was
like people would rather you have been
married and divorced than not marry they
would like
that for me yes they would rather you
been Looney road on that forever road I
read right away uh and divorce right
away and then I bought many five years
hey I did that I touch great school it's
so true but I want to talk about the
girl you're currently dating I always
like asking this especially of my smart
guy friends why why oh just uh I mean I
met her I know why but knew her for a
long time
dated years and years ago and then
stayed friends they're hot and then I
sort of in the back we had going and
then you know people you have to know
because usually people date and they go
out right away and it takes a while to
know how people are general disposition
is important to me they say it takes two
years to fully know someone right
because see even have you ever broken up
for someone or stop seeing them and you
see how they handle that well that's so
interesting you know crazy and you go oh
this is decided in C or you do it and
they handle it with class and grace and
you're like oh wait actually yeah you
look back to that and go I never had
super highs and low as it was all you
see so many different ways they handle
grief or handle this just casually cuz
you're just living your life and being
around them and it sort of makes a
better shape but we used to always talk
about general disposition like sometimes
people I can't say what I am cuz I don't
know looking this way at me but when I'm
around people I like someone who's
medium to upbeat persona instead of hmm
there's some that are so down you're
always trying to get to even get to a
level like they're like sad or like how
is it alright you're trying to get the
balls in the air to get them to have a
good time and it's very rare and the
most time they're like it's just been so
tough you know people I give it a guy
like that super downer yes and then
they're like a little depressing it's
always like hey you having fun and I
know couples like that ones always
trying to pull the other one off it's so
interesting one is like it really is a
recreating her childhood circumstances
thing you know of like if you're used to
entertaining someone and trying to make
someone happy I mean I did that for the
longest time because it was so hard to
make my primary caretakers happy that I
would just do that in relationship those
called parents the parents primary
caretakers yeah I've never heard that
we're attracted to people with the
negative
these are our primary caretakers I
negative quality Wow I just call him
that because some people don't have
parent I was raised by my aunt for a
really long time but I do think that in
my 20s I very much was just recreating
my childhood circumstances with the
people I dated because that was familiar
and then I was like oh no I don't have
to date someone who like needs to be
rescued all the time who needs to be
retained and who's a bummer and like I
don't have to I can have dogs that need
to be rescued I I have that too you know
you look at like my dad was a big
drinker and he was he took off we were
four so you have to look back to
everything that's happened since and go
it didn't affect me then you go actually
it did because then you go
it comes out in ways and then you're
like am I like him am I not like him
what obviously there's gonna be parts of
it like my dad and I don't want the bad
part so I got to figure out if there's a
way to choose out of that and not
recreate just a pet I don't friends are
like my dad was a drunk I'm a drunk
we're all drunk tonight yeah you know
you don't have to for sure just roll
with it you know because we have
addictive families we're all fat we all
eat it I go are you ever addicted
anything good for you
yeah no the easy ones hookers in the car
yeah and at work and volunteer is it
quinoa exit yeah
why are you addicted to cleaning trash
on a beach yeah those never quite caught
on but did go back to shrooms and so you
have all these people that I do see the
recreating I know a buddy that is sort
of recreating in not a great way his job
and you go that's refills company sort
of making his later years exactly like
that yes and good for a better friend it
is comfortable and you can you can see
other people doing it but there's
nothing you can say because a lot of
people are comfortable and what would be
painful for us is their comfort zone
right and there's and people love
adrenaline too I mean people love
adrenaline they love to feel needed some
people love it took me so long to
understand that some people want to live
in constant drama and that serenity
makes them anxious and nervous I know
girls that not even that I've dated just
that I'm friends with them you just
watch him and you just look from a
distance going so glad I'm not your
boyfriend is it like it's so fucking
dramatic and they put their boyfriend
through the wringer so hard and then
they're like you know then they the guy
they break up and then they
you know the breakup get-together drives
people bananas even from the from the
cheap seats he goes yeah I can't watch
anymore and then you just want to jump
in and go fucking go your separate ways
but it's never worked you telling
someone that has never never worked and
then they always go I've changed you
know that little thing was bad for me
and they're exactly the same yeah they
just get a new person and exactly create
the same pattern just see it's not
working somehow I don't know how but
some people love that now I finally
don't judge it you know like I used to
be like why doesn't ever want to live
the way and I'm like if you want I did
that I know that is you need the
distraction you see chaos I don't
haven't figured out you might I don't
know you seem pretty together but you
you are you an over-thinker this is a
good question what am i Benton no
comment
I it depends on what I'm doing to think
a lot
yeah it's exhausting for wait you are
it's exhausting yes I would say thanks
yes wait you're awake a lot is it hard
now shut down and go to sleep very hard
that's I think nightmare do you sleep I
think smart people do that I sleep fine
but I I see people when they have a lot
and and everything about meditating and
things I even got a nap and it's like
everything's about shutting off your
mind and minds like okay lights out but
other view like they say they cycle they
have like a few thoughts that are just
going so fast their head they can't
think of anything else they can't go to
bed let me ask you something do you not
get scared in your house cuz didn't you
get burglarized or something recently
90,000,000 what did you ask me oh boy
what oh I thought you said how much was
it
no it's God it's a shit all but all
right into your house your house is very
it is kind of like when I was 20 what I
thought of that house would look like
it's very there's like marble it's it's
not but it's not like you mean what you
mean is it's a beautiful house no I know
but it's minutes it's more modernist
right yes
it's very um just lacquer it's very
shiny wet with the lacquer right all
right that's the old Beverly Hills
houses that's a dark black lacquer e
mirrors there before you yes Zsa Zsa
Gabor no I'm kidding
there are some of my rooms that look
like jaja because it's from 1970
mirrored closet doors like it no well I
haven't gotten everything it's very sexy
house okay you switched it very sexy
house listen you can do coke off the
door you'll have a weird cliff like I
know it looks like a giant comedy store
the most horrifying description
economies are green room is such a piece
of marble like it's just it's very oh
there's one like I hope you wear shoes
with tread in here
this is so horrible my you know when
Andy and Katie were would come I would
say they have such good taste and I go
come do the salt motherfucking house in
right cuz Andy's like we're might start
hotels called the spades and I'm like
let's do a dry run with my house if you
know what the fuck you're doing
but Annie has two storage units full of
art along with whatever yet honest he
has every square inch of his walls with
stuff I also what is this I'm obsessed
with families that have more than one
successful person and as offspring like
how are you both how is your doing no no
I don't think that has to do with your
dad no one was really would have guessed
from either of us for sure it's very
bizarre that both you and your brother
is very Wilding and different like you
probably has more money than you can you
know Annie yeah oh don't do it but I can
just say yes yes fight his I throw mine
away did you um did you know that was
there just air one version of when you
air this what is that air drop I think
you say drop no when does the pod drop
stream remember when Macy Gray was
walking with a sandwich no MTV Awards
and it says album dropped September 11th
2001 I was like yeah I didn't do well I
don't think anything should drop on
September 11th is a general rule she
said airplanes and my album no no nope I
refused do not do it don't laugh at it
it was a test
I'm for you because you're horrible
person cuz you laughed and I was saying
it as a test I laugh I can laugh at
offensive things all comics do no jokes
that's the different I know their jokes
and you go this guy wants planes fall
this guy he likes September 11 seal I
it's how we cope of course I don't I
think cuz we're I don't know how your
upbringing was but I think you cope by
trying to joke about shitty situations
yes doesn't make them not shitty it
doesn't make him you say you're you know
who Bob Saget is so he's like the king
of this one time we were you know his
sister had died of this horrible like
skin disease yes I went to one of those
benefits am I saying scleroderma X is
close X is Clara Dharma
it's flu and he jokes about it in a way
that is we were one time at a restaurant
in New York eating lasagna and he's ok
could you stop eating my sister Jesus
Christ too far from me we laughed for
like 40 minutes yeah yeah he's good at
that and he also at least it disarms you
from being so nervous or it it's like
you want so badly to for no-one to be
hurt and yes you know he also his act as
dirty as I have two kids I love him you
can do they're in my trunk $20 you know
I mean he talks very fast about these
dirty jokes he's got a funny thing where
I think Stamos was like this was where
they they ran such a cheering up there
was such a clean show that they would
let you know that they were very r-rated
yeah you know yeah well yeah cuz he did
would always do the the Olsen twins joke
Yeah right you never did any the roasts
I did one roast they did a Rob Lowe when
was that
o reason it was two years ago yeah I
hosted it really took some hits I've
been putting it off cuz I listen has a
joke ever hurt your feelings oh yeah
really yeah why that's why they're all
anymore everything I was like I get it
man I don't want it I like jokes going
that way
I don't want him this way why are people
still talking about that was that a big
deal at the time it was a big deal of
time because to have a huge SNL guy call
me at work and lay me the fuck out like
unbelievably I was like this in Chris
Rock was on the other phone going he
wants to get away from me just to
salvage his relationship with Eddie he's
trying to push me was it so you did a
joke on SNL I'm making fun of Eddie and
then he called you are you guys fine now
I saw him last night really we are fine
finally he didn't like it laid me out
and I loved him
well yeah but I did a joke about me and
like it and you know people go oh you
know his first specialty shitting on mr.
t like everybody but I couldn't get that
in through the screams I was more like
in shock and I wasn't gonna talk back to
him I was just I took it I took it I
said I'm sorry and I didn't mean for
like that I think you're fuckin great
blow ah fuck you fuck you and then not
me he said then yeah we hung up oh snap
so then it was this lifelong problem and
he wouldn't do SNL anymore he wouldn't
come on SNL he wouldn't go to read and
so when he hosted he said I'm gonna drop
this thing I have about this bait I'm
gonna drop it and I'm gonna forget about
it and I'm gonna host and I'm it's all
behind me and it took that long Wow and
so it was uh but but you know it sort of
affected me in a weird way because
people always knew about in Rock every
couple years ago I saw Eddie this
weekend still hates you and I'd go
goddamn I just felt bad because he had
to hear my name because they bringing up
interviews ago you still matter what
it's like I just didn't like it I just
didn't like what happened I was mad at
him I was mad at Lauren and it's nice
that it's sort of over now any Indians
have to hear my fucking name of my one
stupid joke along there we go so but
truth is I don't like Joe oh I did SNL
when I left they did a bit about me
three shows after I left I was like
goddamn let me but that's just the way
it is you know our show does it and I
make fun of myself so whatever you make
fun of yourself yeah but some I think on
those roasts and stuff every now gets
rough mmm
does it you've been on my but do you do
anymore no I almost did the last one
Alec Baldwin III was great I came very
close to doing it I loved him him him
and I had a project together that didn't
happen for a litany of reasons and and I
just had it but you know it's like they
say the person and I just instantly had
a bunch of really good jokes sounds like
I just you know but I was promoting the
last special and I when I do roasts I
really prepare I mean you know you
I really prepare what I do you're a
writer and you're smart and then you
actually do it right but the roaster a
dulce was a writer on the roasts first I
wrote through Flavor Flav I wrote for
Ocean um Saget did Amy I know I didn't
do one with Amy I've never done one with
Amy
what was she write her first or she just
come on do her own I don't remember okay
so yeah any Jeselnik was a writer for
sure we overlapped I think one year and
then I wrote for a couple other ones and
then I kept trying to get on them and I
did a roast for Steve Tisch who what
does he own the Giants right and we
filmed it gave it Tommy central they
hired me for the Larry the Cable Guy
roast then unhide me for it and then I
ended it the first one I did which was
Joan Rivers and when you've never done
anything they're great you know that cuz
they just don't know what to get you
you're a whore you're coming your mouth
you know I mean greg Giraldo had the
best joke I feel like the Joan Rivers
roast about me he just went Whitney
Cummings is here for some reason perfect
but then once you've done some stuff and
you know it was just it would get more
and more brutal it was a lot about like
my body and like like plastic surgery
jokes and you know stuff that was just
like she's anorexic and vampire like it
was kind of that but when they don't
know you if you did it to me I would
know that you there you're pulling back
on some you're just trying to get some
good jokes in yeah but if someone
doesn't know you it's fucking brutal
like coming in and taking your legs at
you I hate fuck you cuz they're not
doing with any sort of love or fun
they're just like I'm here to make a
name for me yes and also but I think
that the appearance stuff is right
that's when it gets rough when you like
this day and age is rougher yeah when
you realize they that your apparent
something or that's what they think well
it's like Lisa Lampanelli I remember
after the roast of I want to see Trump
actually we cried because she had just
lost all this weight and you know they
were making fat jokes about her and you
know fucking black guys but she was
married to a white it was kind of like
you know we know why they have to write
the jokes they have to write but it's
still it's like one will get through
that will like hurt you of course
yeah I could well and the roast with Rob
Lowe the ones that got me I don't think
I was too crushed because they were I
also take clever over me and you just
want him to be yeah clever and you got
that's a good one but it has to be mean
to be funny I mean and it's also having
written on the Rose for so long even
people you really like that are really
talented like we can't get you on you're
not being funny we can't yet get you out
having be a bad career we can really
only get you on like your exes or your
like it's just like the people that get
hurt the most the some sometimes are the
ones that have the least to make fun of
because you have to dig deeper into
weird places yeah and if in career
stuff's always hard
yeah it's oh I mean our older also says
something funny once on the red carpet
because I I mean if I greg Giraldo
always was the funniest at the road and
he always was doing like pilots that
didn't get picked up or TV shows that
didn't go and that's always what we got
him on cuz you could never say it wasn't
funny and so people feel again and you
know we better get this over with before
it gets canceled because greg Giraldo is
here like those were always the jokes i
remember he's on the red carpet once and
one of the correspondence was like hey
greg like what do you think of the fact
that you know you never do TV shows or
all your stuff gets cancelled and he
goes when did it become so embarrassing
to just be a comedian for a living yeah
like he just like was like why am i you
know and by the way in this day and age
yeah it's a great time to be a comedian
for a living well it's also so funny
when you respect it too I'm like on a
tour I'm doing stand-up I'm kind of just
trying to focus on doing you know
specials and stuff and people come up to
me like what are you gonna do a TV show
it's like we do I have to do for you we
what we don't do stand-up to get TV like
that's not now you can do TV to get
stand-up okay movie cuz well then I'd
have to go to Atlanta for four months
and cancel a tour but most people make
more money doing stand-up if you're
doing well that's like to do a movie and
not all movies pay well I never made a
shitload of movies I made more maybe
you're like a movie star oh you're a
movie star I was about to leave it I
guess
oh yeah I know I have to ask you some
questions from Instagram because people
will say that are lates a week I don't
believe that you don't make money in
movies that's why I make something I
don't make like what probably people
think I'd make but people I mean you
have like iconic movies don't you get
like Joe
don't you get money when they get bigger
and bigger I don't think so
really yeah you so much money you don't
even know why there's it you are making
yeah I did you chopstick yeah so I did
some Joe Dirt hats last year because
people where I'm and asking about him
when I go I got online there's three
thousand people that make chowder
yeah son bum it's from a mom lip balm
and um there's it's I'm in a bit there's
two Joe Dirt car washes there's there's
so much Joe Joe shut up do you have
nothing that's real it's all someone he
never did any how do people love that
movie so much it's a great question I
think it was me for once playing a nice
character I was friendly I was oh god I
was getting bullied and shit on and
people related to it Oh interest and I
had a good positive attitude yeah and I
kept trying to get through his ad you
can't quit in life and something about
it resonated I'm telling you I I didn't
know we did I thought was just weird and
different like Raising Arizona kind of
yeah poor and it came together and it
really gets to people like they go I
grew up on that and I try to live that
mantra and I try to feel so I love I
love that in a way that not all movies
that I do especially you know I've done
probably 25 movies and people talk about
six of them that's fine you know they
don't talk about the oven they don't do
that great yeah but if you can get a
couple that they like and have so much
fun with it's great kid eyelines okay go
ahead give me a question um what's a
joke you wish you wrote Oh a weird
question it's a good question there's
one there's so many out there that I
think they're fucking great it's a weird
question though because sometimes I see
jokes I think we're all so I'm like I
wish I'd wrote it but I can't do it
wouldn't work as well it's like clothes
it's just not gonna look as good on me
there's a couple where I go oh fuck yeah
I know I just see I get jealous of other
guys a lot I don't know if I wish I
wrote them but I get I go that's a
fucking great one yeah who do you like
coming up right now comedian like oh we
have some you guys you guys do have your
I do think your show is now becoming
almost like what The Tonight Show used
to be I know that will those days are
over but in terms of premium blend or
those shows that used to have like the
best up
coming comedians I think is your show I
like when you said tonight you better
don't you I love watching those we had
this guy Dylan the other day
Tim Dylan is so ho fuckin funny
well you met no there's Tim Dylan who's
now returning to regular but there's a
kid named Dylan Sullivan when he came on
did his tight 5 set oh yeah yeah cuz we
better be a little dirty we let him do
want to set they can't do it and I think
every single one they've never done any
TV before so it's a great first time out
they've all done well and then I do hear
that let your distantly supporting
comedy getting place where people can go
watch a new comic yeah and like building
careers I mean it's really like you know
getting people the ability to like
regular comedian I must feel like you
that come in in between tours and pop in
and do a quick TV spot and go back out
and then people get to see you just see
you again real quick you ever like is
ever weird to pair people or you're like
yeah we do think about it because some
like if we have you we don't have to
have two people that are um so we don't
have to have once we know the gyro
Sharpshooter cuz Whitney's a killer on
there and just in general and you're
gonna bring it we can put someone hasn't
been on before just in case
uh-huh you know and they don't quite get
with the program right away it usually
takes one or two times and anyway but
yes collide no Justin Theroux wrote a
question for you and I sort of got he
responded to it but people want to know
what's the most expensive thing you own
um I mean my house but uh is that the
dumbest answer yeah I mean it's a true
answer it's my house I'm fascinated by
this cuz you to me are such a like
weirdly down-to-earth person and you
don't spend money on stupid shit
he drives a Land Rover from like 1998 95
landcruiser thank you and I Drive I like
it I love it and what is that it's just
I bought a new well half the shit is my
neck okay so it's whatever I don't have
any seats with leather seats neither do
i i have cloth but for different reasons
right
why is that why do you want them to be
cloth seats I just better my bet I don't
know my neck is better so I just buy
cars that are like so all my cars are
sitting even though I love cars I would
waste all my money on cars if I could be
the comedy star parking lot right now is
Ferrari yeah that's real wait have you
ever seen this in comedy where all of a
sudden comedians rich nail cool cars it
was always like dude open a yellow Aston
Martin who came up in a Ferrari the
other day who is that I know chef has
one I can't remember who he is a red one
I can remember who came up at a frog
there's a couple there and there's just
good cars I think we're gonna have some
cool cars very cool there's a lot of
guys that like cars and they have the
money for him I don't have enough
driveway but I could keep a couple year
I go I went to a car auction in Arizona
last week I was trying to get more in
Arizona all the time from there Dumbo I
know that boat was money so it's that
whole fourteen keep going I know okay
what a Justin one what I feel like we'll
cut some of the time soon I really will
cut some of the top of this I have to
get I'm watching the wrong Missy afters
have to go home in there what's that
it's a movie idea comes out in May oh
the one you didn't ye yeah oh good I
have never seen it so uh do is it scored
though just music it's finished oh good
totally finished it already I didn't
want to see I go I don't wanna see any
wait till stuff who are you watching it
with Adam eating it's coming over okay
um you wanna watch with a group of
people yeah swore tea yeah oh good Rosie
and Bobby my friends in the show
wait let's before you go we need to
decide what you're getting Rosie for um
no yes we do what are you getting her a
Teddy longer I don't I don't get that
corny should I get something cool like
what I don't know a gift card
I think gift card is the best Applebee's
Ablett no I think I think you should get
our candles mm-hmm everyone knows I love
candles
I'll get her vagina candle oh yeah I
think they should make a butthole one
does she have a new butthole one coming
out no I don't know well what are you
gonna get her let's decide stop saying
it again why cuz Valentine's Day is a
fucking scam it is not a scam i I mean
it's just a made-up
holidays this super great guy says
capitalism by the way no matter how it
came about it's fucking real bad at
being nice to us we had to make invented
a to force to be nice all day oh shit
yeah or at least at night this is what
it came to
but it's I agree that however it came
about it's real and you better do
something yes that's all yes you know
what else is manufactured holiday the
Superbowl I don't even love this super I
like all the way up to accept a policy I
feel fucking cool I feel like you you
play who fantasy pool really how are you
doing isn't that cool girls love it
hey Rosie anything hey you know that so
today I had Patrick mom she just stop
stop I don't even understand you no one
understand that you have to watch all
the football to yeah everyone's
statistics have to be fucking smart are
you doing good I was your team doing
well are you a good fantasy coach you're
like is your team I don't understand
sorry you have P players on a lot of
different teams and then you make up
your own team you draft though this I
broke this it's uh you draft it whatever
it's too so boring people to now what
else do you know they won't they're
gonna love this David Spade talk about
fantasy football
that's a that's a hot clip we'll get
that one Entertainment Tonight
this one to fucking bars I would like to
give myself credit for number one not
asked to marry Chris Farley on an issue
that was a very conscious choice good
and I was trying to not ask you anything
that you're normally asked I didn't ask
you about The Bachelor
it's true yeah I'm gonna watch it this
week though cuz I know you're obsessed
with it is that irony lost on anyone
that that's your favorite show mhm it's
just fun to watch but I watched even the
one with the guy the girl and all the
guys that's the reps it's still funny
yeah still everyone do you watch comedy
or no mmm like TV why I want no I
watched when I pop at the store and
watch people live I mean like calm it
like scripted I feel like Comino
watching reality show you don't really
walk honey to us anymore people you
million by the way I've probably seen
about four episodes of friends that's
kind of a hot take really never saw I
can tell I can say this with maybe lying
I've never seen five lips as a friend
really
Wow so I like Janney I like Jen anyway
I'm gonna tell her okay for her you just
love them for that I think it was more
blinding jealousy than I think because
the show is such a monster and we're on
at the same time
just shoot me and so we were still maybe
top 10 top 15 but you but how hard was
that we're audience not against but we
were on the same network yeah we had
friends er Will and Grace Frasier
all these great shows so it was hard to
stand out Seinfeld they were all in the
same time hmm same you know Ellen was on
at that time Ellen the TV show sitcom
show yes I actually loved that show she
was in the mix of all that crossfire too
because I was very tough yeah no she
would do jokes about it on the ha ha ha
ha that's funny
so whenever cuz she had a coffee shop
and when people will come in and there
was one time Janeane Garofalo was on the
show and was like hey for the friends
feeling it was like can I get hot
chocolate and Ellen what do you think it
says Central Perk like she would make
jokes about it Ellen which I was so
funny
she's always got in funny ownership all
right we have to get you out of here I
gotta go because I'm more I'm collapsing
I can't believe you're here I came but
you did this yeah I thought that was
like really funny I think we should cut
some of the top though cuz I feel we
were just getting into it I think people
like the bullshit you think of us
sitting in and just bullshitting about
whatever see like even this people don't
care I would watch oh there's your thing
that you're always wearing your Moncler
liner monkey yeah your montclair is that
what you really cold it that's the most
expensive thing he owns by the way what
is that 3000 what is tied up in cash you
know I stayed up good I love like look
at my shoes that's good I'm careful
those are very fancy Yemen orange did
you get those I get them from work and I
steal them because they give me a new
one everything this is like the most
awkward ending to any part what is it
trickle oh um I love you so much thank
you thanks for wearing your vest
[Music]